When a reboot is announced, many moviegoers
decry Hollywood of being unoriginal and out
of ideas.
Why return to a well that’s been played
out when you could just try something new?
But that viewpoint is somewhat limited.
Every once in a while, filmmakers can take
old material and put a refreshing new spin
on it, generating interest in a once fading
brand.
Here are Screen Rant’s 5 great reboots that
were better than the original movies.
Mad Max: Fury Road
George Miller’s Mad Max franchise always
scored well with the critics, but 2015’s
Fury Road was on a whole other level.
The reboot was one of the best reviewed films
of the year and was seen as a game changer
for the way action movies should be made.
It was also nominated for 10 Academy Awards,
including Best Picture and Best Director.
That’s quite an achievement for what was
once thought of as an R-rated niche flick
and not much else.
In addition, it had an impressive run at the
box office, paving the way for more sequels
set in the post-apocalyptic wasteland.
Dredd
Lots of viewers love Sylvester Stallone, but
there weren’t too many fans of the action
legend’s take on Judge Dredd.
Critically panned and a flop financially,
the comic book adaptation killed a franchise
before it truly began.
It took years for someone to try to revive
it, and in 2012, Dredd came out.
The reboot was seen as an innovative use of
3D and a film that did supreme justice to
the source material.
Karl Urban won many people over with his dedicated
performance, which included never removing
the helmet.
While Dredd was a critical smash, it bombed
at the box office, meaning the sequel is a
no-go.
Ocean’s Eleven
Getting a bunch of smooth criminals together
to rob casinos is a great premise, but the
1960 version of Ocean’s Eleven didn’t
strike a chord with moviegoers, who found
it to be disappointing and boring.
Over 50 years later, Steven Soderbergh assembled
a team of Hollywood A-listers to try it again,
and the results were much more successful.
Critics praised the remake for being slick,
breezy entertainment, and audiences basked
in the chemistry between the stars.
The response to Ocean’s Eleven warranted
the release of two sequels, creating a trilogy
of capers that the original could only dream
of.
Star Trek
The original Star Trek TV series is one for
the ages, but the first Trek movie left a
lot to be desired.
Its sequels were marked improvements, but
the brand truly didn’t get a new lease on
life until J.J. Abrams’ 2009 reboot.
Though some were upset by its reliance on
action set pieces instead of heady sci-fi,
Star Trek brought in a whole new generation
of fans while honoring the property’s storied
history in an effort to please all.
The film even earned a Best Picture nod from
the Producer’s Guild of America, a claim
that not many popular blockbusters can make.
The Incredible Hulk
While only a marginal step up from Ang Lee’s
2003 take, the MCU canon reboot did prove
to be a greater success.
Taking the criticisms of the first film to
heart, The Incredible Hulk ramped up the action
sequences to give fans some smashing set pieces,
and Edward Norton delivered a typically great
performance as the lead.
Box office wise, the film only earned slightly
more than the ’03 version, but it earns
points for being a solid hit and not killing
interest in the character.
For all intents and purposes, the green giant
was fully integrated into the shared universe,
and nobody was complaining.
Those are our picks for great reboots that
were more successful than their original.
Are there any we missed?
Which ones are your favorites?
Sound of in the comments section below and
be sure to subscribe to our channel for more
videos like this one!